en sommes maintenant rendus à période de
questions et de réponses orales sans
applaudissements je cède la parole à
monsieur cher le coût social
merci merci de ce président j'aimerais
tout d'abord félicité et remercié le
premier ministre d'avoir accepté cette
invitation de rehausser le décorum de
cette assemblée nationale du québec
merci monsieur paul mus il ya maintenant
un peu plus d'un an le président premier
ministre annonçait que l'effet libéral
amènerait richesse et investissement
douze mois plus tard force est de
constater que l'économie continue de se
détériorer
le ministre des finances nous a
d'ailleurs annoncé la semaine dernière
que les chiffres ne tenait plus la route
après trois mois de l'exercice financier
le déficit budgétaire est de 675
millions de dollars alors que nous
devrions nous engager pour avoir une
véritable politique économique et
industrielle afin d'augmenter nos
revenus premier ministre a décidé de
couper dans ce qu'il ya de plus
important dans une collectivité
l'éducation
la preuve est faite depuis toujours ici
et ailleurs les nations qui se sont
enrichis sont celles qui ont investi en
éducation or il se trouve que le
gouvernement fait l inverse
est ce que la politique du premier
ministre sert à limiter les aspirations
du québec ou soit il véritablement
enrichi des québécois alors monsieur le
premier ministre je vous ai tendu la
main un peu plus tôt pour que nous
puissions nous engager dans notre
développement économique
je vous pose la question n'est-il pas
encore temps de nous rassembler pour
nous enrichir collectivement
presque eu des applaudissements écoutez
il y avait beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
thèmes dans cette question dont je
prends le dernier finalement parce qu'il
y en avait trois ou quatre auparavant
la question d'un sommet économique ce
camp c'est quelque chose que notre
collègue a mentionné quelques reprises
évidemment on agit concrètement sur le
terrain je pense que hier les
travailleurs de courbure les deux cents
soit 10 travailleurs ton sauver l'emploi
savez très bien pourquoi en effet dans
et pour qui on est je pense que les 1000
travailleurs de nuit savait également
très bien pourquoi nous étions je pense
que les travailleurs n'aient le crif
retient sur la côte-nord qu'on a gardé
en vie littéraire et non dans une
période extrêmement critique le savez
également
je pense que les gens de bécancour qui
ont été touchés bien sûr par la
fermeture de la centrale nucléaire qui
ont vu l'annoncé de l'investissement de
stock dans le gaz naturel liquéfié
savent qu'ils ont un gouvernement qui
lobe secret de prospérité création
d'emplois la réalité monsieur le
président c'est que les schistes
malheureusement un peu pour notre
collègue ne m'emporte
en fait si je résume très simplement on
a créé cinq fois plus d'emplois dans le
même temps que nos prédécesseurs
si je résume encore plus simplement
près de la moitié des emplois du secteur
privé crée au canada ont été créés au
québec ce qui est un signe
d'investissement et confiance et si je
résume encore une fois monsieur le
président on risque de multiplier des
thèmes comme mon collègue le fait dans
sa question
l'équilibré budgétaire n'est pas facile
il sera atteint car nous devons
l'atteindre pour nous mêmes et la
génération qui nous suit justement nous
permettre de mieux soutenir notre
mission fondamentale une de nos missions
fondamentales qui essaient de
l'éducation souhaite tourner une réponse
claire du collègue qui ne s'est jamais
exprimé clairement
est-ce que lui quoi ou pas l'équilibré
budgétaire si oui pourquoi ils
critiquent toutes les mesures qui
permettent d'arriver si découvre pas ils
le disent
produire complémentaires seul chef de
l'opposition si le président cette bonne
garde annoncé avant la rentrée
parlementaire et nous nous en
réjouissons que vous avez sauvegardé 270
emplois mais j'aimerais lui demander
qu'adviendra-t-il des 85 emplois et
familles de la machine numéro 9 un
allemand qu'adviendra-t-il des
travailleurs de la loue tinto alors que
st-pierre qu'arrivera-t-il des 3600
employés ou travailleurs qui ont perdu
leur emploi depuis juin
alors monsieur le président premier
ministre va-t-il persister à vouloir
seulement coupés ou présentera-t-il un
véritable plan de développement
économique sur le premier ministre